[Music]
I can't believe that I was worried about
hurting you I should have kicked her
with your cousin when I had the
opportunity because I was at some party
she said she had a talk to me
and then she didn't say anything can't
believe it I was worried about hurting
you while you were banging around the
bars trying to scrape up something new
you left me 50 bucks nothing else to do
but think about getting back at you
[Music]
and I heard that you've been back around
the neighborhood and you might be strung
out but you still look pretty good I
heard that kid from California turned
out to be a rascal I could have told you
but you're left with Burning Bridges and
you never saw the beach you had stars in
your eyes but Modesto's not that sweet
when you only know one guy
for days at a time
[Music]
thank you
but I was
so without hurting you
I should have kicked it with your cousin
when I had the opportunity that was at
some party she said she had to talk to
me
and then she didn't say anything
[Music]
[Applause]